Вітаю! Ми знаходимось на уроці з
геометрії за темою:
«Тригонометричні функції гострих
кутів прямокутного трикутника».
Мене звуть Олексій Печериця.
Перш ніж приступати до вивчення
нового матеріалу,
опрацюємо деякі опорні поняття. Отже,
перше: що таке прямокутний трикутник?
Прямокутним називають трикутник,
один із кутів якого прямий.
Зауважимо при цьому, що два інші
кути цього трикутника обов’язково гострі.
Наступне запитання: сторони
прямокутного трикутника.
Сторони прямокутного трикутника мають свої
назви. Ті дві сторони трикутника,
які утворюють прямий кут, називають
катетами,
а сторону, яка лежить
навпроти прямого кута,
називають гіпотенузою
прямокутного трикутника.
Наступне: подібні трикутники.
Трикутники називають подібними,
якщо відповідні їхні кути - рівні,
а відповідні сторони - пропорційні. Тобто
відношення відповідних сторін однакове.
І останнє запитання: ознаки
подібності прямокутних трикутників.
У прямокутних трикутників є
свої специфічні ознаки подібності.
Одна із них каже про те, що
прямокутні трикутники подібні,
якщо в них однакові гострі кути. Тобто
достатньо лише одного гострого кута.
Друга ознака подібності прямокутних
трикутників каже про те,
що два прямокутні трикутники подібні,
якщо їх катети відносяться пропорційно.
Тобто, достатньо лише двох
катетів. І не потрібно порівнювати кути.
І ще одна ознака каже про те,
що прямокутні трикутники подібні,
якщо у них однаково пропорційні
один із катетів та гіпотенуза.
Перейдемо до вивчення нового.
Перше поняття, яке ми сьогодні
розглянемо – це поняття синуса.
Отже, синусом гострого кута прямокутного
трикутника називають відношення
протилежного до цього кута катета
до гіпотенузи. Поглянемо на креслення.
Отже, маємо прямокутний
трикутник АВС із прямим кутом С.
Тоді синусом кута А називають відношення
протилежного до цього кута катета,
тобто катет АВС до гіпотенузи АВ.
А, відповідно - синусом
другого гострого кута, кута В,
називають відношення протилежного
катета АС до гіпотенузи АВ.
Наступне поняття – косинус.
Це також співвідношення між катетом
та гіпотенузою, але тепер трошки інше.
Отже, косинусом гострого кута
прямокутного трикутника називають
відношення прилеглого до
цього кута катета до гіпотенузи.
На кресленні це буде виглядати так:
косинусом кута А
прямокутного трикутника
АВС із прямим кутом С
буде відношенням катета АС до гіпотенузи
АВ.
А косинусом кута В, який є другим
гострим кутом цього трикутника,
буде відношення катета
ВС до гіпотенузи АВ.
Бачимо, обидва рази катети, які
беруться у відношенні, є прилеглими.
Тобто утворюють одну із сторін кута.
Наступне поняття – тангенс.
Тангенсом гострого кута прямокутного
трикутника називають відношення
протилежного катета до прилеглого катета.
Тобто, якщо маємо прямокутний
трикутник АВС із прямим кутом С,
тоді тангенсом гострого кута А буде
відношення протилежного катета ВС
до прилеглого катета АС,
а тангенсом гострого кута В
– відношення протилежного до нього
катета АС до прилеглого катета ВС.
І ще одне відношення,
четверте - котангенс.
Котангенсом гострого кута
прямокутного трикутника
називають відношення
прилеглого катета до протилежного.
Тобто, котангенсом гострого кута А
називають відношення АС,
прилеглого катета, до
протилежного катета ВС.
А, відповідно, для кута В
відношення буде задаватись так
– котангенсом кута В є
відношення катета ВС до катета АС.
Зверніть увагу! Значення
синуса і косинуса гострого кута
прямокутного трикутника повинні
міститись у межах від 0 до 1.
Логічно, оскільки синус і косинус
– це відношення катетів до гіпотенузи.
А оскільки гіпотенуза є найбільшою
стороною прямокутного трикутника,
то це відношення не буде
перевищувати одиницю.
Другий момент, на який
варто звернути увагу.
Тангенс і котангенс гострого кута
прямокутного трикутника
– величини додатні.
І ніяких обмежень згори вони не мають.
Перейдемо до розв’язування задач.
Перша задача на сьогодні
буде виглядати наступним чином.
Трикутник зі сторонами
15 м, 20 м, і 25 м – прямокутний.
Обчислити тригонометричні функції
меншого кута цього трикутника.
Зобразимо цей трикутник
і почнемо розв’язання.
Отже, нам дано прямокутний
трикутник АВС із прямим кутом С.
Один із його катетів становить 15,
другий 20, а гіпотенуза 25 метрів.
Менший з кутів цього трикутника
буде лежати навпроти меншої сторони.
Тобто у нашому випадку навпроти катета АС.
Таким чином нам потрібно знайти синус,
косинус, тангенс і котангенс кута В.
Для цього пригадаємо означення.
Отже, синусом кута В буде
відношення протилежного катета,
тобто катета АС, до гіпотенузи АВ.
Відповідно, маємо 15/25,
скоротимо цей дріб на 5 і отримаємо 3/5.
Бачимо, дійсно, наш синус
міститься між нулем та одиницею.
Наступне.
Косинус кута В.
Косинусом є відношення
прилеглого катета ВС до гіпотенузи.
Маємо 20 поділити на 25.
Скоротивши дріб на 5, отримаємо 4/5.
Наступне. Тангенс кута В.
Це відношення протилежного катета АС
до прилеглого катета ВС.
Відповідно, 15/20 або 3/4.
І останнє співвідношення.
Котангенс кута В буде
відношенням ВС до АС,
тобто прилеглого катета до протилежного.
І, відповідно,
ця величина становитиме 20/15 або 4/3.
Бачимо, хоча тангенс у нас і вийшов
величиною,
що міститься між нулем та одиницею,
котангенс, на противагу йому,
виявився більшим за одиницю.
І це – нормально.
Адже на тангенси і котангенси немає
обмежень у величині згори. Продовжимо.
Наступна задача.
Катет і гіпотенуза прямокутного
трикутника дорівнюють 24 см і 25см.
Обчислити тригонометричні функції
більшого кута цього трикутника.
Дивимось. Дано: прямокутний
трикутник АВС із прямим кутом С.
Один із його катетів становить 24 см,
а гіпотенуза 25 см.
Про другий катет поки нічого не відомо.
Для того, щоб з’ясувати величину другого
катета, застосуємо теорему Піфагора.
За теоремою Піфагора матимемо наступне:
сума квадратів катетів цього
трикутника дорівнює квадрату гіпотенузи.
Тобто,
АС квадрат + ВС квадрат = АВ квадрат.
Звідси, для того, щоб знайти катет АС,
виразимо величину АС квадрат.
Вона буде рівна АВ
квадрат мінус ВС квадрат.
Підставимо числові значення.
25 в квадраті мінус 24 в квадраті,
маємо 625-576.
І це дорівнює 49.
Звідси робимо висновок,
що катет АС має довжину 7 см.
Тепер можна говорити про те, який із
гострих кутів цього трикутника є більшим.
Бачимо, якщо катет АС =7 см,
а катет ВС = 24 см,
то катет АС менший за
катет ВС і відповідно кути,
що лежать навпроти цих катетів, так само
будуть пов’язані таким співвідношенням.
Звідси робимо висновок,
що кут А більший за кут В.
I нам потрібно знайти тригонометричні
функції саме для кута А. Продовжимо.
Першим будемо шукати синус.
Синус кута А - це буде відношення
протилежного катета ВС до гіпотенузи АВ.
Тобто, 24/25.
Косинус кута А – це відношення
прилеглого катета АС до гіпотенузи АВ.
Або ж 7/25.
Тангенс кута А – це відношення
протилежного катета ВС до прилеглого АС,
24/7.
І котангенс кута А – це відношення
катета АС до катета ВС, або ж 7/24.
Задачу розв’язано.
Розв’яжемо ще одну задачу,
формулювання якої виглядає так:
у прямокутному трикутнику АВС
з прямим кутом С відомо, що ВС = 5 дм,
а косинус кута В становить 2/5.
Знайти довжину сторони АВ.
Виконаємо креслення.
Маємо прямокутний трикутник АВС
із прямим кутом С.
ВС складає 5 дм.
Косинус кута В = 2/5.
Знайти сторону АВ.
Оскільки кут С за умовою задачі прямий,
то сторона АВ є гіпотенузою
нашого трикутника.
Тоді, записавши косинус кута В, отримаємо,
що він дорівнює відношенню
прилеглого катета ВС до гіпотенузи АВ,
а вже звідси можемо виразити довжину АВ.
АВ, таким чином, буде становити
ВС поділити на косинус кута В.
Подивимось що це вийде.
ВС за умовою задачі становить 5.
Косинус кута В – 2/5.
Пригадаємо: для того,
щоб число поділити на дріб,
потрібно це число
помножити на обернений дріб.
5 помножити на 5/2 = 25/2
або ж 12,5 дециметрів.
Відповідь: АВ = 12,5 дециметрів.
Наступна задача має такий вигляд:
діагоналі АС і ВD ромба
АВСD дорівнюють 24 м і 10 м.
Обчислити тригонометричні
функції кута АВО,
де О – точка перетину діагоналей ромба.
Зобразимо цей ромб, перш
ніж починати розв’язання.
Отже, маємо ромб АВСD і знаємо,
що його діагональ АС = 24 м.
Діагональ ВD = 10 м. Крім того,
ці діагоналі перетинаються в точці О.
Знайти: синус кута АВО, косинус
цього кута, його тангенс і котангенс.
Для того, щоб розв’язати цю задачу,
потрібно згадати декілька
простих властивостей ромба.
Діагоналі ромба
перетинаються під прямим кутом.
І точкою перетину діляться навпіл.
Отже, відрізок ВО дорівнює відрізку ОD,
а відрізок АО дорівнює відрізку ОС.
Оскільки за умовою задачі
діагональ АС дорівнює 24 метри,
тоді відрізок АО буде становити
половину від цієї діагоналі.
І його довжина складе 12 метрів.
Аналогічним чином відрізок ВО
дорівнює половині діагоналі ВD.
10 навпіл, отримуємо 5 метрів.
Розглянемо прямокутний трикутник АОВ.
Трикутник АОВ із кутом
АОВ рівним 90 градусам.
Тоді в цьому трикутнику за означеннями
тригонометричних функцій синус кута АВО
буде дорівнювати відношенню
протилежного катета АО до гіпотенузи АВ.
Катет АО = 12, а гіпотенузу можемо знайти,
скориставшись теоремою Піфагора.
Корінь із суми АО квадрат і ОВ квадрат.
12/√(144 + 25) = 12/√169 = 12/13.
Косинус кута АВО дорівнює
відношенню катета ВО до гіпотенузи АВ.
Тоді, матимемо, що катет ВО = 5, а
гіпотенузу ми звами вже порахували, 13.
Таким чином косинус кута АВО
становить 5/13.
Тангенс кута АВО – це відношення
катета АО до катета ВО.
І це відношення буде дорівнювати 12/5.
Котангенс цього ж кута –
це відношення ВО до АО.
Або ж 5/12.
Задачу розв’язано.
Перейдемо до підсумкового тесту.
Перше запитання.
У трикутнику АВС катет ВС і
гіпотенуза АВ дорівнюють 3 м і 5 м.
Обчислити косинус кута В.
Кут В у прямокутному трикутнику
утворений катетом ВС і гіпотенузою АВ,
а отже косинусом буде відношення
цього ж катета до гіпотенузи.
Маємо, що таке відношення повинно
становити 3/5. Правильна відповідь: А).
Друге запитання.
Прямокутний трикутник має
сторони 8 мм, 15 мм і 17 мм.
Обчислити синус меншого кута.
Оскільки в цьому трикутнику
сторони 8, 15 і 17 мм,
то сторона довжиною 17 мм
– це його гіпотенуза.
А менший кут лежить
навпроти меншої сторони.
Тобто навпроти катета довжиною 8 мм.
Синус меншого кута – це і буде
відношення катета довжиною 8 мм
до гіпотенузи довжиною 17 мм.
Правильна відповідь: 8/17.
І питання номер три.
У трикутнику АВС кут С прямий,
катет ВС = 4 см, а котангенс кута А = 4.
Обчислити довжину катета АС.
Ще раз, котангенс кута А – це відношення
прилеглого катета до протилежного.
Тобто відношення АС до ВС.
Тоді АС:4 = 4, звідки
отримуємо, що катет АС становить 16 см.
Пролунав дзвоник, нам пора відпочивати.
Не бійтеся розв’язувати
задачі і все у вас вийде. Успіхів!